as we start exploring the world of
statistics it's worth asking ourself
what does the word statistics even mean
and statistics is really a broad
category of things that you might do
with data
so it generally deals with data
collecting data so actually let me write
these down it's involving collecting
data
collecting data you could present data
in tables or charts or just as lists of
numbers or however you might do it it is
analyzing the data
analyzing
presenting and analyzing data so this
whole class of just you know all the
stuff that you might do with data to to
answer question or try to figure out
what's going on or just to learn about
the world that whole class of things is
called statistics
now an idea that will come up very
frequently in statistics is the notion
of variability
variability
in everyday language variability it's to
it's it's how much something is how much
does it vary how much does it change and
it's the same notion statistics in
statistics variability is the the degree
to which data points are different from
each other to the degree to which they
vary and this is an example of that just
make it a little bit more concrete let's
say you were to go to five people and
you were to ask them
how many
how many bricks did you eat yesterday
and each of the people say well i you
know person wants if i don't eat bricks
at all i don't i don't even know how to
do that i ate zero bricks and then the
next person says zero the next person
says zero fourth person says here and
the fifth person says zero fair enough
so that was our data point on the
different data points on and i'm already
doing statistics just by going out there
and asking them how many bricks they ate
but then i asked them how many how many
grapes did you eat yesterday and the
first person says
i ate zero grapes but the next person
says i survive on grapes i ate 235
grapes the next person says oh yeah i
like grapes i ate 17 grapes then the
person after that says that they ate
five grapes and the next person also
survives on grapes even to a larger
degree they eat 318
grapes
so if you look at these two data sets
one is the number of bricks someone ate
yesterday the other one is how many
grapes they ate yesterday you
immediately see that there's more
variability here all of these data
points are zero while these they change
a good bit from data point to data point
so we have a sense that there is more
variability in this data set now one of
the things we will start doing a lot of
statistics is trying to measure how much
more how much variability is how can we
quantify that how can we put a number on
it how can we measure variability this
is a big aspect of statistics but we
won't do that in this video there are
future videos for doing that
but just as we go into the world of
statistics we should think about well
when do we even you know when should our
brain even start getting into statistics
mode thinking about the tools that we
have at our disposal about collecting
data and and measuring variability and
measuring and finding numbers that
somehow represent a data a pool of data
that has variability and so the question
we should ask ourselves is what
questions in the world are statistical
questions
so statistical
statistical
questions
so let's come up with a definition for a
statistical question the type of
question where we would want to start
bringing out our statistical our
statistical toolkit
well one possible way to think about
when you need to bring out your
statistical toolkit is these are
questions that to answer them
to answer
you need to collect data with
variability to answer you need
to collect
data
with
variability and apologize for my
handwriting
data with variability that's w-i-t-h
data with
variability
so you're saying okay that kind of makes
sense but i need to see some tangible
questions tangible examples of things
that are statistical questions and
things that are not statistical
questions and i would say fair enough
let's look at some examples
so here i have six questions and i
encourage you to pause this video right
now and before i work through it think
about it based on this definition of a
statistical question which of these
questions are statistical would require
your kind of statistical toolkit and
which of these are not statistical
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
let's go through these one by one
so the first question how much does my
pet grapefruit weigh now it's bizarre to
begin with to have a pet grapefruit but
is this a is this a statistical question
well what do i need to do to answer it i
have to take my pet grapefruit out i
have to weigh it and then i have to just
write that down and just doing that i am
collecting data so you know you could
you could argue that maybe i'm kind of
starting to mess with statistics a
little bit
but i'm just getting one data point so i
might weigh it and i might see my
grapefruit weighs one
one pound
but that's not data with the variability
that's just one data point in order to
have variability i have to have multiple
data points and it should be at least
possible that they could vary
so for example these all of these folks
ate zero bricks but maybe it was
possible that someone actually ate a
brick but here i just have one one data
point with one data point you can't have
variability so this is not a statistical
question i just collect a data point
next question what is the average number
of cars in a parking lot on monday
mornings well to think about whether it
is a statistical question we just have
to think about what do i have to do to
answer that question
well i would have to go out to the
parking lot on multiple monday mornings
and measure the number of cars so on the
first monday morning i might see there
are 50 cars the next monday morning i
might go out there and count there's 49
cars the next monday morning i might see
50 cars again the next monday morning i
might see 63 cars so i'm collecting
multiple data points to answer this
question then i'm going to take the
average of all these but i'm i'm
collecting multiple data points to
answer this question
and so and
and it's definitely possible that there
could be variation here that there could
be variability so this is a statistical
question
next question am i hungry it's an
important question we need to ask it to
ourselves multiple times in fact
sometimes well our bodies just tell it
to us but i am definitely not collecting
i guess you could say i'm collecting
some type of feelings from my stomach or
how weak i feel or not
but it's definitely not data with
variability i'm either hungry or not
hungry on a given day i mean if you said
broader you know how does my hunger
change from day to day and you came up
with some type of a scale for rating
your hunger hey maybe that's more more
statistical but just am i hungry a yes
no question this is not this to answer
this i do not have to collect data with
variability so this is not a statistical
question
how many teeth does my mother have
to do this i would have to go find my
mother and then i would have to ask her
to open her mouth and count the teeth in
her mouth and maybe i get a number like
30. so it's kind of like how much does
my pet grapefruit weigh i i do have to
do i have to do i do have to collect one
data point
but one data point is not going to have
variability so i am not collecting data
with variability so this is not a
statistical question if i said how many
teeth do all of the mothers did i know
have on average or what's the range of
number of teeth that the mothers i know
have well that that would start getting
that or that would be statistical but
this is just one data point so not
statistical
how much time do the members of my
family spend eating per year
well once again what do i need to do to
answer this question
well i would have to go either observe
or survey my family members you know
maybe my mom my wife my children
and my uncles aunts whoever else i would
say well how much do you eat each day i
would add them all up to figure out how
much they eat in the year and maybe you
know family member a eats 813 hours in a
year family member b
eight
i don't know
732 hours in the year
and so you see the general notion that i
will be collecting multiple data points
from the different family members and
they're very well and in fact there's
very likely to be variation in that in
fact i might even see variation from
year to year person a is probably going
to need a different number of hours in
the in the next year so i'm definitely
going to collect data with variability
in order to answer this question so that
is a statistical question
and then finally i have the question how
many times have i watched star wars well
this is very similar to how many teeth
does my mother have or how much does my
pet grapefruit weigh i just have to
count the number of times that i watch
star wars and maybe you know it's i
watched it seven times just one data
point no variability here if i said on
average how many times have my coworkers
watch star wars well then i'm going to
have to collect data with variability
i'm going to collect multiple data
points and it's definitely possible that
my co-workers have watched it different
numbers of times but for this question
in particular there's just one data
point to answer it how many times have i
watched star wars and my answer in this
case actually i think is seven well
they're not a statistical question
so hopefully that gives you a sense of
statistics variability and what a
statistical question even is